[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey folks welcome back this is the Q&A
portion of the eighth livestream with me
Brett Weinstein dr. Heather hanging to
my right shall we get to the questions
let's get to the questions you guys
wrote a lot in and we are as we
mentioned in the first livestream going
to change our tactics here a little bit
we've simply gone through and ranked
them by amount and we've got 20 up high
here that we're going to try to get
through in this first half an hour which
means we'll miss a lot of your questions
for which we apologize and then we will
switch in this in the second half hour
of this Q&A livestream to answering
questions that you write in for this
second livestream so without further ado
is it possible to somehow cultivate a
strain of the virus that arts less
damaging that could be used for herd
immunity can the genetic mutations of
the virus play a role in the symptoms
yeah I mean I would say that this is a
one of the primary strategies of how a
vaccine works so an attenuated virus
might be used to trigger immunity
I guess the question differs slightly in
the sense of something that was
transmitted person-to-person and
basically like a contagious vaccine I
would say I don't know of that being a
strategy that has been employed yet I
could be ignorant to something but my
guess is is just far too dangerous to
set something loose that can then change
under evolutionary pressure even
potentially recombine with the thing
you're trying to immunize people from so
it's not inconceivable but it would
require a lot of thinking good next
question can the ongoing sanitization
result in a super bug yes it could
I'm gonna go the other way on this wine
I feel like we may have had this
question at earlier Q&A yeah I hear this
one periodically I would say the it
depends what you mean if you're talking
about the sanitization with alcohol and
UV light I would say that these things
do not tend to select for highly
resistant bugs that would then be
difficult to challenge and if you did if
you did have that effect you could drive
the percentage of alcohol up rather
rather easily to address the problem so
I don't you think if you know what's
happening if you knew there was a
problem happening yeah I don't think
that this runs the same risk is like
antibacterial soaps presumably many
people especially since for instance
isopropyl alcohol became unavailable
very early in this many people are still
using these antibacterial soaps which we
know widespread use of has been
correlated with increase in allergies
and autoimmune disorders and children
right right which is different than a
super bug so there there is the hygiene
hypothesis for allergies which is
credible but a virus is not a bacterium
it doesn't have the same vulnerabilities
and so we will address them differently
but my basic feeling from the beginning
has been actually you're relatively safe
with with alcohol as a disinfectant and
it will it's not going to create a
superbug good next question could you
explain the personal responsibility
vortex more detailed than in your TED
talk Brett I did not understand the
similarity between individual and
company choices since companies are
losing income based on their decisions
whereas consumers don't I can't do a
better job than in the TED talk that was
a 12 minute talk and we don't have that
kind of time but I will say people are
in an analogous position to corporations
in the sense that if they spend based on
let's say say you buy organic shampoo
which has no
extra value over a cheaper inorganic
shampoo then you are spending more to
make the world better and you therefore
have less resource to for example send
your kid to a higher quality school well
there they will network with more
powerful people and the folks next door
who bought a shampoo that works just as
well but cost less have extra income to
spend on their kids their kids go to
better schools they have more influence
over government the world begins to look
more like the one they would have us
live in than the one you would have us
live in so the organic shampoo turns out
not to be assuming it doesn't have a
health benefit which I would assume
organic shampoos don't it will the world
would look more like your competitors
dream world and less like yours so
anyway I'm sure that confused matters
more than it needed to but maybe we'll
link to your TED talk as well in the
description of this episode fair enough
it's very clear I think that is a decent
segue to the next question what does a
normal day of eating look like for you
two well as you now know we don't eat
organic shampoo right yeah not at all if
we were gonna eat shampoo I would insist
that it be organic absolutely especially
for the children do you want to you're
gonna feel this or uh geez I mean let's
say you know we live in the Pacific
Northwest which is surprisingly great
for raw ingredients we now live in
Portland which is surprisingly great for
prepared foods as well we do a lot of
cooking at home now I mean now we're
doing all of our cooking at home right
so we've eaten nothing prepared by
anyone else for over a month at this
point yep I would say we are pretty
strict about organic produce we've we've
been I mean this this war it's a much
longer conversation and there's a whole
chapter on food in our forthcoming book
but we have for instance dabbled in
intermittent fasting there seems to be
good evidence for this being a useful
tool in
and how humans can be healthier and more
productive and you know reducing
certainly simple sugars and to some
degree complex carbs in favor of good
fats and and sugars from from produce
and veg and a lot of good protein yeah
air conditioning does it increase the
spread of virus because of air
circulation doesn't mean no centralized
AC is this summer any filters that can
work so we actually you know you didn't
know that we were going to go there but
we we got there at the end of the last
live stream I have not heard of filters
being put in place but I feel like this
is an obvious place for our need to be
ramping up and you know viruses are
viruses range quite a bit in size but
they're obviously quite small compared
to the kind of stuff that often gets
collected in filters so I don't know I
don't know what the state of that
research might be let's just say there
are filters that can do it in general I
mean there's a rating system I think
it's Merv mu r v4 particle size
filtration anyway look into it there are
also filters that do contain UV
sanitizers found to be helpful but
anyway I think the UV sanitizing is not
in the filter itself but it's like in
the in the larger unit so it requires
would require a redo of the unit that
you're using actually often it can just
be inserted at the air handler you can
just basically swap a box in for some of
the sheet metal that would be there and
I don't know how well it works but yeah
it has been studied to an extent it
would be great to have data on how this
particular pathogen interacts with it
data proved to be useful is there a
possibility that the amount of male and
female sperm a male produces is
dependent on the ratio of men and women
around them which could explain the male
boom after World War two oh I see the X
versus Y bearing yeah so this is a this
is a a possible mechanism for the
Traverse Willard hypothesis
in some ways right without it doesn't
specify the turret rivers Willard
Traverse was our undergraduate adviser
Bob Trevor's one of the greatest living
evolutionary biologists the trophies of
Willard hypothesis suggests that
individuals who are in better health and
are they're wise high-ranking are more
likely to produce more males as
offspring and those who are in poorer
health or otherwise lower ranking or
more likely to produce females and that
sounds like an appalling prediction
until you think about what it is that
high-quality males can do in the world
and just stop thinking about humans at
all for a moment and imagine a moose
high quality moose male moose is more
likely to get matings whereas all female
moose are likely to be able to go on to
reproduce so that's the basic hypothesis
trevor's Willard that that quality of
our screen just went blank Zack quality
of okay you go Brett basically
evolutionarily you don't want to be a
loser mail because loser males don't
tend to reproduce and therefore you
would only want to produce males were
you going to produce a male who was well
positioned to be successful so anyway
you would expect Tobias I see no reason
that you couldn't have a mechanism like
the one you described and my Judaism
again being a sperm ratio of male to
female sperm as X or Y sperm and mammals
dependent on the ratio of men and women
around them that's the mechanism
proposed here yeah so it's it's
conceivable yeah so to speak nice
question seven how would you advise a
pre undergrad with learning differences
dyslexia slower processing in finding
educational and research facilities
enabling them to exercise their
strengths and pursue big questions in
evolution oh boy this is a heartbreaking
question at some level I used to know
this really great little public liberal
arts college in the Pacific Northwest
where you could go for such things I
can't recommend it anymore it's a really
tough question higher ed is broken at
some
levels and in general as an undergrad
you will get more attention and more
ability to have your individual
differences recognized and perhaps
taking advantage of in the in the good
way at a smaller college the liberal
arts institution that at a big
University like an r1 on the other hand
you there's going to be a lot more
research going on and r1 and there are
probably lab research opportunities but
you're more likely to be washing
glassware then actually involved in
high-level discussions about hypotheses
an experimental design let's try this a
different way okay
the world is screwing up it is throwing
away lots of highly ethical but unusual
Minds it should be engaged in arbitrage
these people are poorly served by a an
academy that is largely staffed by
people who were themselves excellent
students and when they find
idiosyncratic people in their classes
don't know what to make of them so
somebody ought to figure out how to
engage in that arbitrage and serve those
people and produce really high-quality
unusual minds that would then enter the
workforce and and innovate so anyway
there's the challenge let's see if
somebody can figure out how to finance
the solution very good why do you think
there's not a widespread move to import
East Asian memes into the West eg not
wearing shoes in the house like is the
norm in many countries which extremely
few Cova deaths per capita it seems like
we need full-on Japan if occation of the
culture in the you know the people who
we hang out with do shoeless houses for
the most part and have for decades I
think so I think that that is spreading
but slowly and in pockets I think right
now we are seeing why masks in flu
season if makes makes good sense because
that's the thing that clearly looks
correlated you know among other things
in those countries that managed to
control the spread of Koba 19 anything
else yeah I think we are going to see
a major reorganization of how we
interact based on the lessons here maybe
shaking hands doesn't come back and my
guess is we've been making a terrible
error with it all along I don't know if
we'll start bowing or what but but
anyway there's a lot to be done we're
learning a lot and I do think we could
also up the ante a little bit I'm not
sure why medical masks are the way
people avoid infection in Asia in other
words why you know we don't wear goggles
if you have a problem with your vision
you know we give you an ability to buy
glasses that look good and flatter your
face or whatever so why are we not
engaged in what sort of scarf would you
want in order to block infections we
should make this less of a difficult
choice for people by integrating it
better into their lives okay what
question was I on number nine do you
have any advice for dyslexics to learn
communication with normies who all
seemed autistic I can't work around the
reading writing issues got a BA and
applied linguistics but all the other
effects of dyslexia seem insurmountable
so what do you think yeah so Brett
you've said on this show before that you
are dyslexic although we both object to
the yeah pathologizing of this condition
but what do you think he's referring to
as the other effects of dyslexia other
than reading your writing issues I don't
know I should say I would be dyslexic if
there was such a thing but it's too much
of a garbage category again the problem
with the binary yeah you know I don't
know what to tell you the my experience
has been I had to do a lot of things
some other way and it didn't always go
well in fact it went terribly for most
of my early schooling but I wouldn't go
back and become non dyslexic if I could
too many of the things that I think are
good about the way I think and function
came from what I learned to do
to compensate for the things I didn't do
as well as other people and so anyway I
would say the best thing you can do is
figure out where you might have an
advantage and figure out how to play to
it next question relating to
metaphorical truth and cultural memes do
you two think there was any relation to
the diseases spread by bats and the
cultural memes that relate bats to death
and vampires that is an interesting
question let us address the vampire if
you first sort of it easier bats were
not helped by the fact that when when
European science got to the new world
there were a couple of kind of bats that
did drink blood and they drink blood
that they lap off the surface of an
animal who they've sliced open and
actually it's funny
many of the fruit bats in the new world
are miss named Vampira actually vampire
was not a fruit bat it's a carnivore but
it's not a blood drinking bat same house
empresa
and protease all there were all of these
bats that are named as if they drank
blood that don't that I have always
taken to be the panic response of
Europeans naming bats that they couldn't
quite identify and assuming everything
was a vampire but in any case the the
connection of bats to vampire stories I
think the vampire stories predates the
European discovery of bats that drink
blood and so the label vampire was
grafted onto the bats and that may have
something to do with it but I also think
that you know night is spooky because we
have diurnal eyes and therefore
creatures that fly around at night and
you know appear to be like they are not
rodents but appear to be like rodents
with a special power it all kind of
naturally points in the direction of
something mysterious and otherworldly
even I mean even we have been spooked I
haven't been one of our first times in
Madagascar we walked up to a tree and I
think it was before dawn we were waiting
for a taxi Bruce this is terrible mode
of transit ground transportation in
Madagascar and we heard some sort of a
wrestling and walked up to it and it
turned out to be completely filled with
these mega bats these giant fruit bats
who poured out the tree and caused us to
do yeah this and all the malla gauzy in
the neighborhood we're laughing at us
for being such ridiculous fahza you know
and as foreigners so you know that at
night when you hear something you don't
recognize and especially if it then
comes at you just because it's also
spooked and it's trying to get away it
is it is scary but you know do you what
do you think the likelihood is that
there have been back to human viruses
being spread before now I mean if before
you answer that if it has been happening
it's been very localized yeah because we
live in an era of globalization which is
why this thing has spread so rapidly it
would have been localized to whoever had
the bat soup or what you know whatever
the mechanism might have been it has
happened with rabies occasionally but
I'm not maybe some virus I'm not
convinced that this is a a proper case
of the meme Konoe ting a epidemiological
problem yeah I just I just don't think
so I think night is spooky and also
probably the fact that bats hang upside
down mm-hmm makes them hard to relate to
yeah yeah have the two of you or Eric
consider trying to make your own
research grant to at least provide some
tiny measure of freedom from the corrupt
academic system to researchers that you
think deserves support well that would
be great if we were independently
wealthy but none of us are so that's not
good yeah we're not even dependently
well yeah I mean so the idea of some
sort of organization you know something
philanthropic as opposed to governmental
and to some degree predatory like NIH
and NSF are
NSF are seems terrific and in fact there
are plenty of smaller organizations that
do give grants for research all of which
have different roles one rule that is
consistent between almost all of them is
that you have to have an institutional
affiliation so that's that's a rule that
is unfortunately pretty universal but
yeah I think you know we need more more
sources of funding all of us but it's
it's not gonna be any of the three of us
that the money is coming from
unfortunately unless things change right
if we were to visit another planet with
carbon-based life-forms would we
potentially be able to eat the plant
animal analogues we find there okay I
want to take this one because I
addressed this exactly I considered this
question quite a bit in a book I've
written that I have I have shelved for
the moment but a science fiction novel
about the search for other forms of
consciousness in the galaxy in which
exactly this question of course comes up
and I clearly we would be able to take
the plant animal analogues that we find
there into its components and then
restructure into something that we could
eat but could we eat what's actually
there it rather depends on exactly how
evolution happened there but it seems at
first pass to me somewhat unlikely yeah
I think it's almost certainly known what
are your thoughts on the claims that
kovat 19 sorry I keep on losing it what
are your thoughts on the claims that
kovat 19 may be disproportionately
affecting people of color if - do you
think this could be biological or
societal or both that's a good question
yep I would say it is it almost
certainly has a societal component it
may have a biological component I would
caution you about that term I would
argue that culture is equally biological
as genes but it is certainly toxic
component it could well have a genetic
component many
medical phenomena do but I very much
want to see and maybe these already
exist there are compelling datasets that
suggest a disproportionate effect on
particularly African Americans I would
like to see a correction for economic
status and location right because lots
of things may go along with what your
racial group is and it would be nice to
know causally whether these things could
be to use Department yeah no that's
exactly the analysis that I want to see
it they the claims look legitimate but I
have seen nothing separating out
specifically socioeconomic status and
and geography do animals have perception
mechanisms and labeling them to infer
that one animal from another species
their plan to eat or share territory
with is an asymptomatic carrier of a
virus they should avoid asymptomatic
almost by definition not I would imagine
and in fact the very fact of many
creatures that eat meat being unwilling
to eat a dead animal and the secondary
fact of many animals were some animals
playing dead to avoid being eaten
suggests an aversion to animals that
might be sick but in a symptomatic case
how would they know I mean almost
anything that would allow them to know
would be a symptom right so again we're
wrestling with this definition of
asymptomatic at some level in
environments where people have
historically died young and made it
early like Africa are people less
selected for fitness in their old age do
they have longer telomeres telomeres and
are they more at risk of cancer you've
got one of the factors reverse it will
certainly be true that in any
environment where you are unlikely to
live to old age
that the alternative to old age which we
call youthful vigor will be favored at
some cost to longevity
so in any case it is quite plausible I
don't know whether your assumptions
about Africa are accurate but let's just
say as a general matter having nothing
to do with human beings environments
that allow you to grow to old age reveal
they basically show selection negative
effects that happen late in life and
selection purges those negative effects
so you'd get greater longevity our cats
genetically predisposed to sit in boxes
are some human behaviors genetically
influenced how this is three questions
in one
how did genetically influence behaviors
get encoded in DNA if not during ones
lifetime so first you would want to rule
out the possibility that the boxes are
predisposed to sit under cats and that's
just an obvious competing hypothesis
that's a that's a confound for sure yep
yeah you can have behaviors that are
genetically influenced and these things
will be the result of relatively simple
cascades of effects that in other words
you're imagining the wrong thing if you
think the DNA has a program in it for
organizing neurons for some kind of a
subjective preference it's much more
likely to be a bias that results in the
triggering of a reward mechanism that
then results in that behavior becoming
ingrained over developmental time humans
are unique we can recognize the game
we're playing and choose not to play it
that's in quotes how does this make
sense in light of evolution it allows
pursuit of things not in the interest of
genes yes we can decide not to play the
game unfortunately when we decide not to
play the game we give an advantage to
those who decide to continue to play the
game and therefore tend to sideline
ourselves evolutionarily now I'm not
arguing that that has to be the case in
fact I would argue we have to figure out
how to stand down that dynamic if we are
to escape the peril we create for
ourselves
in the 21st century but by and large if
you take the example of can you decide
to resist the evolutionary drive to
reproduce of course you can and many
people do they tend to be out reproduced
by those who didn't though and so at a
competitive level it's not like you've
actually defeated the game you've just
sidelined yourself so there are ways out
thinking about how they might work is
well worth the effort so three more
questions in this and then we'll go to
the super chat questions from the
current live stream years ago I jokingly
told my college girlfriend that my
uncouth behavior was not my
responsibility because generations of
women had selected for the kind of man
that I had become in hindsight was i
right No oh I was gonna say yeah of
course you were right yeah no
unfortunately it's true
well uncouth behavior is not not
heritable mostly at the genetic level it
doesn't need to be genetic though
because the fact is to the extent that
men are rewarded for bad behavior they
tend to propagate that bad behavior to
their sons and male collaborators and
all now lots of terrible things can
spread this way to having nothing to do
with females selecting for them so males
overriding female choices is the same
thing it's a viable strategy that is
abhorrent and and you also have no
cultural pleiotropy so effectively where
there's a lot of stuff that people put
up with because it seems to come with
the whole package yep and that doesn't
mean that it's been selected for it
means it's a hanger-on I tell you what
let's deal with this proactively instead
of talking about responsibility for the
past can we just simply employ our
female followers to stop sleeping with
[ __ ] all right good I think we
covered that okay
what would be the evolutionary idea and
why some people can lucid dream yeah
it's good I would look at this a
different way some fraction of dreams
are lucid it's a rare phenomenon in
normal dreaming but it happens that
lucid dreams being dreams in which you
are aware you are conscious inside of
your dream that you are dreaming and
some of us who have dabbled in this have
developed a capacity to navigate
consciously to an extent so the question
really I think has to do with why the
border between conscious waking thought
and unconscious sleeping dreams is
porous and I will just leave you with
the following thought sometimes the
content of dreams which your conscious
mind would not have good access to is
actually handed across that border upon
waking those of us who do some
problem-solving in our dreams sometimes
find a thought is almost handed to our
conscious mind by our unconscious mind
at the point of natural waking and very
rarely if ever happens when the alarm
goes off and jars you awake but if you
allow yourself to awake naturally
there's a point you arrive at in the
dream the conclusion of the dream may be
of some significance and then your
subconscious mind hands it off to your
conscious mind you say aha that problem
I've been struggling with I think I know
the answer so that I think hints at the
the conclusion which is that the border
is not a hard and fast rule because
sometimes it is useful to bend it and
then people being able to develop the
capacity to bend it at will is another
question is that useful or not I would
just add one caveat you said those of us
who problem-solve in our dreams I would
think that all of us every one of us
problem solves in our dreams but some of
us do not have explicit handoffs from
the unconscious to the conscious mind
but we we wake better able to do
something be it skiing or math or
knitting or whatever it might be then we
were able to do before we went to sleep
so there's problem-solving there's
which are different but I think both
things happen for everyone in their
sleep although not everyone experiences
a conscious Eureka moment upon waking
ever yeah I guess the reason I'm not
saying dreams stand any chance of being
other than adaptive and useful
cognitively but some of us have had the
experience of some particular thing with
which we are struggling that we went to
sleep without the answer and we've
awoken with the answer and the answer
clearly is the result of processing that
took place during that time the other
experience of you know I get better at X
Y or Z thing even when I'm not paying
attention to it and dreams are a very
strong contender for the place where
that occurs I guess I'm just using
problem solving narrowly rather than
broadly mmm-hmm oh and dreams and also
non REM sleep
appears to be a place where a lot of the
physical learning is happening actually
great ok so one more question and then
we'll switch to the questions in the
next live chat livestream rather how
does suicide and depression fit in the
evolutionary model are they not
antitheses of survival instinct or just
non adaptive evolutionary byproducts you
know I have long wanted to advance the
argument that suicide as we find it in
modern circumstances is largely
maladaptive but that the tendency to
have that option available is utterly
adaptive and in an ancestral context you
would find it deployed almost
exclusively adaptively my friend David
Lodi and I once filed an abstract to
give a talk on this very topic and it
was rejected I can't even recall
abstract being rejected for it I give a
talk at a conference that both qualified
dear give the talk but anyway um
certainly Lodi was your co-author on
your evolution of morality paper yep
he's a good friend so anyway let's just
say this topic needs very careful
thinking lots of things are
transmissible evolutionarily that seemed
at first
to be maladaptive but have a hidden
logic to them and so suicide and
depression are both strong candidates
for this Randy necie who was a mentor of
mine many years ago has done a lot of
work on the question of depression
mm-hmm okay Zach are we looking you know
wait what is this here we go so
everything is in grant having a hard
time reading this cuz it's all grayed
out yep so I'm gonna pull on you Brett
oh there we go
that's helpful but where do I start
fifty-seven right here he says okay so
we'll spend a half an hour just going
through these in the order they came in
and then we'll stop when we stop okay
first question are you aware of
historical epidemics for the category of
asymptomatic has been has been
eventually revised to something like
symptomatic in a way that hasn't as of
yet been identified as relevant it's a
super interesting question I am not
aware of that
I feel like this this pandemic has the
greatest chance of of recategorize in a
symptomatic in that way especially as
these you know we've got like chilblains
which i think is the technical term for
this you know these really swollen red
toes and fingertips which is a which is
a symptom in quote-unquote otherwise
asymptomatic carriers we talked about
anosmia the loss of sense of smell and
taste
there are presumably others of these
things where oh you're asymptomatic but
you just are experiencing something
weird well maybe that's actually a
symptom that isn't yet diagnosed yeah
and again we want to know what the lung
x-rays reveal in so-called asymptomatic
cases because would we even call that
asymptomatic if your lungs show up as
heavily damaged even though you're not
experiencing any external signs I would
say that's not asymptomatic
yeah any relationship tips on dealing
with disagreements well you want to take
a crack at this and all correct well
we've talked before matter of fact I
think you may have said when we were
together on Rogan that turning down the
sound is is a really good way to observe
what it is that the emotional and
visceral stuff is playing out how it's
playing out in front of you and it can
be completely infuriating to the other
person if you're not on the same page
but being able to step away from
language for a bit in order to see what
what is actually being conveyed without
language is super useful yeah to step
outside of yourself and recognizing that
the argument is very often not about the
content of the argument it's about
something else it's about somebody
feeling shortchanged or something like
that and it manifests in some sort of
explicit context about some particular I
don't know slight but that's not really
what it's about in roots trying to
figure out what it is really about is is
useful and also just the simple
recognition that you are a creature who
is very much
you calling me a creature I am calling
you that I'm actually calling you an ape
yeah you are a creature who cannot help
but be mostly a mystery to yourself and
that means that you are not always in
charge of your emotional state or the
arguments that you're deploying or what
you choose to be upset about or anything
like that and just the simple ability to
communicate to the other person that
you're aware that although something is
very important to you you're also
potentially aware that that might be a
you know a ridiculous preoccupation at
the same time the two things can be true
in in my case with you I very frequently
find myself if if I'm doing something
that's driving you crazy
I very often feel like oh I know exactly
why that's driving you crazy I'm not
happy about it you know if I could turn
the thing off I would but I can't and so
it's sort of like yeah I'm with you on
this one
you know the guy he was doing that
maddening thing you know it's you and me
against him right but unfortunately he's
in charge unfortunately he's in charge
yeah we're not gonna win this one but
you know yeah we could for a while okay
is interest-bearing debt based currency
an evolutionary environment we're in a
fitness of strategies to find revolved
for instance embedded growth boy we've
got a lot of it started out strong but
we got lost it's it's the it's now the
top one is interest-bearing debt based
currency an evolutionary environment
we're in a fitness of strategies is
defined or evolved eg embedded growth
right I recognize all the components
here embedded growth obligations comes
from Eric an environment where in a
fitness of strategies is defined
revolved boy you might want to refine
this question so we can tackle it better
clearly our debt-based currency sets up
a landscape of assets and liabilities
hazards perverse incentives that then
causes the evolution of many different
strategies so I don't know if that
answers your question if it does we got
it if it doesn't try refining it what
are your thoughts on the work of dr.
Chandra Ricker Wickramasinghe and the
possibility of Corona like viruses
making their way to us from space never
heard of her
seems like the chances of that are close
to zero I would say they approach zero
just very very close to zero basis that
the in actually we're gonna jump to next
question on line 66 if we encountered
extraterrestrial life how different
could it be at the molecular or DNA
level if it's a truly extraterrestrial
it's going to have a different what I
call in this science fiction novel that
I wrote an info mall and different
information molecule entirely so the DNA
is just it's not kind of have DNA it's
gonna have something some molecule by
which it transmits information to its
its offspring and you know is it likely
to be carbon-based maybe maybe silicon
based those seem like the most likely
elements because of their particular
chemical structure but even if it's a
carbon-based that doesn't mean that it
is going to be that did it's in foam all
its information molecule is going to be
anything like DNA so I feel like I
dressed that one and interrupted you on
this question of what is the possibility
of coral like viruses making the way it
was from space I would just say the very
fact that coronaviruses carry their
information in the form of RNA that
masquerades as messenger RNA which can
be read by the ribosomes of your cells
pretty much tells you that they came
from the same tree of life they can't
have originated from different ones yeah
so we've got we've got an origin of life
from which all extant life on Earth
originates and it's really easy to tell
if that's not the case at this point
what is a good technical source for an
engineer to get into the mathematical
formalism of evolutionary theory I don't
think we're ready for the mathematical
formalism
in other words one of my complaints
about the way we do evolutionary theory
is that we have rushed to instantiate it
in a way that has sometimes been
illuminating but it has then constrained
us over time and I think there's a lot
of stuff plainly going on in adaptive
evolutionary space that we can't spot
because it doesn't hand the mathematic
it doesn't fit the mathematical models
that we've been handed by our immediate
ancestors but I guess I could say from
sort of around the time of the so-called
modern synthesis in the early mid
twentieth century we have our a Fisher
so this is you know this is not modern
evolutionary thinking but it's still
mostly holds re Fisher is also known as
the father
moderate statistics he was also a
remarkable mathematical evolutionary
mind and I can't put you to any
particular texts but anything Fisher has
written is going to be mathematically
explicit and evolutionarily relevant
yeah there's a lot of good stuff but the
problem is you want to pick it up
without allowing it to constrain what
you're capable of contemplating toxic
sunset question what is the difference
between deductive and inductive
reasoning could you illustrate these two
concepts with examples that relate to
the scientific method what is a toxic
sunset question yeah I don't I don't
know I mean you know we can talk about
inductive and deductive and obviously
the scientific method uses both well no
not really
for one thing I always confuse the two
but what what brings me what what does
my pneumonic for it is remembering that
the scientific method is best understood
at least in a pop arian sense as
hypothetical deductive yeah in which
hypothesis is the stand-in for inductive
reasoning where the hypothesis is taking
general observations and or is it this
is this is where I get confused general
observations and positing a particular
meaning for them as a hypothesis and the
deduction that follows would be taking
the particular testing it etc taking the
particular and generalizing from it and
claiming that there's a general truth
yeah that's still very broad and
theoretical but the the to the reasoning
from general to specific and reasoning
from specific to general need to be
happening
you know simultaneously practically or
at least both within any process they
need to be trading back and for treating
back and forth that's matter and both
both need to be happening in order for
the complete scientific discovery loop
to happen yep
yes the wim HOF method it looks like
nobody mentioned wim HOF this time fixed
okay mentioned our ethics committees as
corrupt as the peer review complex
what can be done about it our ethics
committees as corrupt as the peer review
complex I know less about how epics
committees are constructed and I and but
if we're talking about the kind of stuff
that's happening over in diversity
inclusion equity space for sure and and
in some ways even more so what can be
done about it
we can stop funding all of the obvious
[ __ ] that's happening in academia
that's one thing that can be done about
it that would be good yeah thank you for
doing this at a time I am awake and able
to watch live from Scotland
you're welcome you have referred to some
Scottish data a couple of times now
could you talk a little bit more about
this you've referenced this I don't I
know catching me a little off-guard I
don't have the paper here but I believe
this was a fairly large-scale study that
sampled the population at random to
assess how many people had had kovat 19
cross Scotland or an ed murrow or
something
it was a subset but I can't remember
okay I can't remember where the the
sampling was done but it appeared to
reflect a fairly high rate of infection
relative to the already known rate of
mortality it was something like one
percent of cases were detected okay um
maybe Zac if you would flag that one and
what maybe people try to find the
scottish data to either post in the
description or mention next time
sixty-five thank you for this
I read opposite opinions on if you can
or should boost the immune system
thoughts also mutiny please know I
cannot live with four more years of anti
science Trump that's to boost of the
immune system yeah I I every time I hear
somebody talk about boosting immunity I
kind of glaze over because in general
that's not how immunity works right you
can inform the immune system about a
particular hazard you can depress the
immune system by
throwing challenges at it that overwhelm
it but boosting immunity is one of these
phrases that gets invoked that I don't
think is particularly meaningful that
said because I for the first time have a
computer in front of me I just found
this paper Luo at all 2020 don't don't
put the screen on Zach that was it
published this year but it was peer
reviewed so it was in the it was in the
publication pipeline for a while but
found that in pigs
early life enrichment versus being
housed in barren cages is correlated
with enhanced immunoglobulin G
production in response to exposure to
particular antigens later later life
enrichment does not have such effects so
I was thinking we talk about this a
little bit on the next live stream which
we may still but it was the first time
so I just pulled that up from my notes
for for next time but I saw something
environmental being correlated with a a
boost right and i GG for for exposure to
particular antigens yes but it also
doesn't distinguish you know is it that
pigs in a non enriched environment have
depressed immunity and that this is
restoring the immunity and that's that's
gonna be yes so what is baseline yeah
yeah let's see deniers of Wuhan lab
Theory the virus is organic and origin
can it be cultivated in populations of
bats to make sure the virus can jump to
humans can it be cultivated to look like
organic I'm just going to say and I saw
Eric tweeting about this today the idea
that the Wuhan lab was somehow involved
is not synonymous with the idea that
this virus was created or altered by
people that is of course possible but
the chances of this virus being organic
being in the lab under study for
whatever reason and escaping is a lot
more likely
what we know so far then that this was a
synthetic virus that was would have had
to be assembled out of a virus from some
creature presumably a bat but in any
case I think people are just simply
synonymous the idea of a synthetic or
altered virus with the fact that the
virus was in the lab under study which
we don't know but is seems highly likely
since there were bat coronavirus is
apparently being studied at this lab so
anyway don't leap to the conclusion that
it's synthetic even if you believe that
the laboratory was likely involved how
does depression function evolutionarily
I think we already addressed this if it
signifies needs are not being met then
why is it so difficult to meet those
needs
when depressed not bandwidth enough here
to take to take care of the question
fully but I would say the fact of
depression being maladaptive in our
milieu does not mean that it is not a
modification of something that would be
adaptive in a different context so we
have a an ultra novel environment that
is taking all sorts of things that would
ordinarily be adaptive like for example
our ability to store excess food energy
that we encounter during some seasons
for use in other seasons that obviously
gets out of control very easily when
there's just too much food resource
available so does that mean storing fat
is maladaptive no but in many cases it
becomes maladaptive because the
regulators on it aren't built for our
environment okay so it looks like we've
got 50 minutes we got five questions
left here and if we have a little bit
more time we'll go back into the other
super channel that we probably want
suggestions of good material on lucid
dreaming I don't know any texts um this
is a long time ago but when I was
experimenting with lucid dreaming
I believe the Stanford sleep Research
Center was mecca for that sort of work
and they had materials available
including some
stuff on how to train yourself to loose
a dream I found it useful certainly fun
if a bit exhausting but anyway I would
see you did you feel less rested after
lucid dreaming yeah often yeah it was it
might steal from some of the important
benefits of sleep and dream I would say
it was a trade-off
they were definitely it was very
enjoyable fascinating but also a bit
exhausting okay
follow-up to not playing the game you've
mentioned this being necessary in order
to navigate to a better world how would
this ability have evolved the ability to
step out of the game yeah well the thing
is what if you see a bigger game right
so I don't want to go too deep in the
weeds here but let's just say as I said
in some of the early live streams
evolutions objective for each species is
to get it as deeply into the future as
it can what if you recognize that by
playing a game local to our era we were
effectively guaranteeing our extinction
in the next 150 years and that in order
to get into an era 500 years from now or
a thousand years from now you
effectively had to stop playing the game
that you were trapped in in 21st century
could you do it the answer is not an
obvious yes but it is a plausible yes in
other words human beings are capable of
abstracting the game and saying yes if
we keep doing this thing it will result
in that that we do not want what can we
do to re our Kotak incentives such that
we can get past that roadblock and
there's there's no obstacle to it other
than the recognition of the bind and the
ability to compel a sufficient number of
people that I mean look it's it's no
different than the wisdom that
accompanies a recognition of delayed
gratification we are all born into a
state where you know we see and we want
and then we learn that actually you
get things that are better than that you
can reach out and touch if you are
willing to to wait and to plan and so we
do that and so it's easier to do as an
individual than it is to do as a society
but it is possible at both levels we've
seen it at both levels and so that's
really the thing is we have to agree
about the peril and we have to agree
that the steps necessary to avoid the
peril are worth it and I think if we
took that project seriously we would
also discover that there were great
rewards even in the short term once we
begin with that project wonderful can
you provide details on how a virus such
as the current one is determined to be
natural versus engineered so one of our
early live streams we talked about a
paper that it concluded that it was
natural quote-unquote organic and we're
still working on going back through
those early live streams and putting the
papers that we mentioned in the show
notes the video notes but um is it how
close a match is it to extant
viruses that are already known and
sequenced and there are these databases
at some point on one of these we're
going to talk a little bit about names
and I'm gonna walk us through the
various levels of nested sets in which
this virus exists and if you have a
match that's really really close to an
existing virus it you know it still may
be recombinant it may be that to humans
combined to extant viruses but it
appears to be based on the existing
viruses and then there's a question of
this is a place where we slightly
disagreed the authors were saying yeah
this doesn't look like the kinds of
changes that someone who is trying to
engineer a virus would have made because
these aren't the obvious changes to make
to other corona viruses and I thought
well if you were actually trying to
engineer
wouldn't you actually make some choices
that weren't obvious so as exactly to
put people off of your trail but there
you know there's a lot that we don't
that you and I don't know about the
difficulty of you know dealing with the
protein code versus you know the spiked
protein and you know all of the vagaries
of viruses yeah I would say the key
piece of evidence would be a in this
case it would be RNA code for which
there was no plausible mechanism for it
to have gotten into a corona virus but
human metal so a recombinant organism
where a recombinant virus that is corona
virus but then has something from
another known animal genome and or
fungal genome or something and we have
no known mechanism for how it could have
gotten there yeah and even whereas we
have this and we know that these like
we're common at bat pengal and viruses
exist for instance and people have put
together plausible stories for how that
might have happened organically yeah so
you have to be cautious just because you
don't know the mechanism by which some
sequence found its way into into this
virus it doesn't mean that there isn't
one but yeah the fact that this virus
does not integrate into the genome
actually limits to an extent what it
could have picked up in its own you know
there may be mechanisms that we don't
know or that I don't know but it's not
hopping into the genome and then hopping
out and capable of taking anything that
it might find there with it as a result
of a different edit mm-hmm because it's
not integrating it's not in a position
to collect that stuff so anyway I would
I would you know look for something that
was just so improbable that it wouldn't
have landed there by any normal
mechanism and the second thing is that
capacity that had been tacked on to the
virus would have to provide some value
from the perspective of the humans that
would have done the engineering so in
other words of some sequence that
additive the capacity to
the coronavirus that would make it
harder to defeat for example would be
suggestive but I have yet to see
anything of this sort yep okay two more
questions one what are the most
important criteria of a game beef
there are two ways to answer this
because it's not really clear what
important means in that question one and
I would say the primary one is that it
has to be competitively superior to game
a in game A's terms in order for it to
be viable but in saying that there might
be lots of things that are superior to a
game a and wouldn't be a true game B
because they wouldn't produce any of the
virtues of the hypothesized game B
environment so I would say high on my
list for things that a game B would have
to include it would have to be
sustainable it would have to be fair it
would have to be liberating those would
be high on the list of characteristics
of a game B world and something that had
those characteristics and was
competitively superior to game a and
game A's terms so also I would argue
resistant to capture or another way of
saying it would be an evolutionarily
stable strategy that is to say a
strategy that maintained its superiority
and could not be invaded by something
that that was corrupt wonderful the last
question is a comment from which maybe
we can riff a tiny bit before signing
off for today lots of talk about how we
perform healthcare politics etc when the
pandemic is over but like changing one
comma and the tax code there are winners
and losers from any change
yeah there gonna be a lot of winners and
losers when this is over just based on
what we will have learned and I think
there is almost no way
to deal with that it's going to be a
it's hard to even know what metaphor to
invoke it's going to be a gigantic
earthquake of change that said it does
point to the necessity of having a
system that protects you from
unpredictable giant earthquakes of
change and I'm not saying that a
pandemic was unpredictable but the
particulars of it clearly was so this
tells us that we need a system that is
built for the next one of these whatever
it is and that immunizes people from
having their lives turned upside down
their ability to earn suddenly ended
that cannot be maintained because the
volatility and danger in the system that
was installed with none of our approval
right all of that fragility was built in
some of it intentionally some of it by
forces of evolution some of it by bad
choice making but the fact is we didn't
design it and we are now at risk of
suffering from it we have to build a
system that protects us from those kinds
of consequences and so yes there are
going to be winners and losers but the
system works best when the losers are
people who are suffering from their own
bad decision making and the winners are
people who are profiting from their good
decision making and good and bad are
defined such that when somebody makes a
good decision it enhances well-being on
planet Earth and when somebody makes a
bad decision it's one that does harm to
well-being and those are the things that
come back to haunt you so again this
goes to the question of game B we need a
system in which those feedbacks are
tight enough that the system evolves
towards desirable ends and we don't have
that system at the moment all right all
right well this has been great we will
do a live stream number nine sooner
rather than later probably a.m. Pacific
Tuesday 3:30
and hopefully we will have further
technical issues solved
we appreciate you bearing with us in the
meantime